blue Marvel is coming to the MCU and I'm  excited because he's the most powerful  character in Marvel Comics that you've  never heard of check this out this guy  knocked out the ultimate Hulk in one  punch he ko'd this guy in one punch he  fought the Sentry Ares the god of war  and Captain Marvel to a standstill this  guy killed the physical manifestation of  shumogorath this guy has basically  conquered entire realities that's what  shimogorath did Blue Marble killed him  in one hit blue Marvel in the Ultimate  Avengers they overpowered galatus and  they finished his transformation turning  him from the world devour into the  lifebringer and in more recent issues in  Marvel Comics the guy killed a beyonder  and I don't even know how someone does  that in any event I'm super hyped for  him to show up make sure you guys follow  for more